hello everybody
good to see all of you please please
have a seat
well hello rockville
uh let me start by
recognizing three public servants who
fight hard every day for maryland
families and businesses first of all
congressman chris van hollen is here
hey chris
congressman john delaney is here
and we have the acting head of the small
business administration uh gene hewlett
is here
and i also want to give a big thanks to
your bosses
sedalia and natalya for being such
gracious hosts i had a chance to meet
them at the white house and
thank you
now i know where they got their good
looks from because i had a chance to
meet mom
and dad and uh their their beautiful
families and uh so i'm i'm so glad to be
here and and i had a chance to to learn
a little bit about their story
so when their parents brought them from
portugal to america
almost 40 years ago
no one in the family spoke a word of
english
but that didn't stop their father
manuel and their mother albertina from
having a big dream
believing that if they worked hard they
could get ahead
and that even though they'd never had
any schooling maybe their daughters
could go to
college maybe in america you could make
it if you tried
that's what they believed so they
started their own construction company
with a pickup truck
and a wheelbarrow
and when
sedalia and natalya turned 14
they began to help cleaning tools
translating documents
and they became the first in their
family to go to college
and after graduation they started their
own business and later they bought the
family business from their parents
so today
m louie's construction is a 60 million
company with about 250 employees
and i understand you're opening your
fourth office at the end of this month
so
this story is what america is all about
you start off maybe you don't have a lot
but you're willing to work hard
you put in the time
opportunities out there
and you're able to pass on an even
better life to your family your children
your grandchildren
and it's good news that
after
how hard the construction industry got
hit during the recession
things are starting to get a little
better
remember it was just five years ago that
our economy was in a free fall
businesses were shedding hundreds of
thousands of jobs every single month
and the recession ultimately cost
millions of americans their jobs their
homes their savings everything they had
worked hard to build
today
over the last three and a half years our
businesses have added seven and a half
million new jobs
our deficits are falling
our housing market is healing which
means
construction is improving
manufacturing is growing the auto
industry is back america is on pace to
become the number one energy producer in
the world this year
more small businesses have gotten loans
so they can grow and they can hire just
like m louise did with the help of the
small business jobs act that i signed
three years ago so that's part of what
allowed
this company to grow
so we still have a long way to go we've
still got a lot of work to do
especially to rebuild the middle class
but we're making steady progress
and the reason i'm here is
we can't afford
to threaten that progress right now
right now hundreds of thousands of
americans
hard-working americans
suddenly aren't receiving their paycheck
right now they're worrying about missing
their rent or their mortgage
or even making ends meet
we can all relate to that imagine if
suddenly
you weren't sure whether you were going
to get your next paycheck
with all the bills that might be
mounting up
well that's what's happening right now
to hundreds of thousands of americans
across the country
companies like this one
worry that their businesses are going to
be disrupted
because obviously particularly an area
like maryland virginia
where there are a lot of
federal workers you don't know how
that's going to impact the economy
veterans
seniors
women
they're all worrying that the services
they depend on will be disrupted too
and
the worst part is this time it's not
because of a once in a lifetime
recession
this isn't happening because of some
financial crisis
it's happening because of a reckless
republican shutdown in washington
now we've all seen the offices locked
down the monuments closed
we've heard about services denied
we've heard about benefits that are
delayed
but the impacts of the shutdown
go way beyond
those things that you're seeing on
television
those hundreds of thousands of americans
a lot of whom live around here
don't know when they're going to get
their
next paycheck and that means stores and
restaurants around here don't know if
they'll have as many customers
across the country you've got farmers
in rural areas and small business owners
who deserve a loan but they're being
left in the lurch right now
they might have an application pending
as we speak but there's nobody in the
office to process the loan
the sba gives a billion dollars
of loans a month to small businesses
a billion dollars a month and goes to
small businesses all across the country
right now those can't be processed
because there's nobody there to process
veterans who deserve our support are
getting less help
little kids who deserve
a head start
have been sent home from the safe places
where they learn and grow every single
day
and of course their families then have
to scramble to figure out what to do
and the longer this goes on the worse it
will be
and it makes no sense
the american people elected their
representatives to make their lives
easier not harder
and there's one way out of this reckless
and damaging republican shutdown
congress has to pass a budget
that funds our government with no
partisan strings attached
now i want everybody to understand
what's happened because sometimes when
this gets reported on
everybody kind of thinks well you know
both sides are just squabbling democrats
and republicans they're always arguing
so
neither side's
behaving properly i want everybody to
understand what's happened here
the republicans passed a temporary
budget
for two months
at a funding level that we as democrats
actually think is way too low because
we're not
providing help for
more small businesses doing more for
early childhood education doing more to
rebuild our infrastructure but we said
okay while we're still
trying to figure out this budget we're
prepared
to go ahead and take
the republican
budget levels that they proposed
so the senate passed that with no
strings attached not because it had
everything the democrats wanted in fact
it had very little the democrats wanted
but we said
let's go ahead and just
make sure that other people aren't hurt
while negotiations are still taking
place
so that's already passed the senate
and we know there are enough republicans
and democrats
to vote
in the house of representatives for the
same thing
so i want everybody to understand this
there are enough republicans and
democrats
in the house of representatives today
that if the speaker of the house john
boehner simply let the bill get on the
floor
for an up or down vote
every congressman could vote their
conscience
the shutdown would end today
the only thing that is keeping the
government shut down
the only thing preventing people from
going back to work and basic research
starting back up and farmers and small
business owners getting their loans the
only thing that's preventing all that
from happening right now today in the
next five minutes
is that speaker john boehner won't even
let the bill get a yes or no vote
because he doesn't want to anger
the extremists in his party
that's that's all
that's what this whole thing is about
and we've heard a lot from congressional
republicans the past couple days saying
they don't want this shutdown
well there's a simple way to prove it
send the bill to the floor let everybody
vote
it will pass
send me the bill i will sign it
the shutdown will be over and we can get
back to the business of governing and
helping the american people
could happen the next
next half hour
national parks monuments
offices would all reopen immediately
benefits and services would resume again
hundreds of thousands of dedicated
public servants
who are worrying about whether they're
going to be able to pay the mortgage
or pay the car note
they'd start going back to work right
away
so my simple message today is
call a vote
call a vote
put it on the floor
and let every individual member of
congress make up their own minds
and they can show the american people
are you for a shutdown or not
if you're not for a shutdown you'll vote
for the bill if your fore is shut down
you won't vote for a bill
we don't have to twist anybody's arms
but that way the american people will be
clear
about who's responsible for the shutdown
or alternatively more hopefully they'd
be clear that
this is something that doesn't make
sense and
we should go ahead and
make sure that we're looking out for the
american people it should be that simple
but as i said the problem we've got
is that there's one faction of one party
in one half of one branch of government
that so far has refused to allow that
yes or no vote unless they get
some massive partisan concessions
in exchange
for doing what they're supposed to be
doing anyway
in exchange for doing what everybody
else agrees is necessary and they won't
agree to end the shutdown until they get
their way
and and you may think i'm exaggerating
but just the other day one tea party
republican called the idea of a shutdown
wonderful
another said that a shutdown is exactly
what we wanted
well they got exactly what they wanted
now they're trying to figure out how to
get out of it
just yesterday one house republican said
i'm quoting here all right because i
want to make sure
people understand i didn't make this up
one house of republicans said we're not
going to be disrespected
we have to get something out of this and
i
don't know what that even is
that was a quote
we we're not going to be disrespected
we got to get something out of this and
and i don't know
what that even is
think about that
you have already gotten the opportunity
to serve the american people
there's no higher honor than that
you've already gotten the opportunity to
help businesses like this one
workers like these
so the american people aren't in the
mood to
give you a goodie bag to go with it
what you get is our intelligence
professionals being back on the job
what you get is our medical researchers
back on the job what you get are little
kids back in the head start
what you get are national parks and
monuments open again
what you get is the economy not stalling
but continuing to grow
what you get are workers continuing to
be hired
that's what you get that's what you
should be asking for take a vote stop
this first and end this shutdown right
now
if you're being disrespected it's
because of that attitude you got
that you deserve to get something for
doing your job
everybody here just does their job
right
you don't
if you're working
here
and in the middle of the day you just
stopped and said you know what
i want to get something but i don't know
i don't know exactly what i'm going to
get but
i'm just going to stop working until i
get something i'm going to try i'm going
to shut down the whole plant
until i get something
you'd get fired
right
because because the deal is you've
already gotten
hired
you've got a job
you're getting a paycheck
and so
you also are getting the pride of doing
a good job
and contributing to a business and
looking out for your fellow workers
that's what you're getting
well it shouldn't be any different
for a member of congress
now unlike past shutdowns
i want to make sure everybody
understands this because again sometimes
the tendency is to say well both sides
are at fault
this one has nothing to do with deficits
or spending or budgets
our deficits are falling at the fastest
pace in 60 years
we've cut the deficits in half since i
took office
and some of the things that the
republicans are asking for right now
would actually add to our deficits
seriously
so this is not about
spending and this isn't about
fiscal responsibility this whole thing
is about one thing
the republican obsession
with dismantling the affordable care act
and denying affordable health insurance
to millions of americans that's all this
has become about
that seems to be the only thing that
unites the republican party these days
through this whole fight
they've said the american people don't
want obamacare so we should shut down
the government
to repeal it or delay it
but here's the problem the government's
now shut down
but the affordable care act is still
open for business
so
so they're not even accomplishing what
they say they want to accomplish
and by the way in the first two days
since the new marketplaces basically big
group plans that we've set up
first two days that they open
websites where you can compare and
purchase new affordable insurance plans
and maybe get tax credits to reduce your
cost millions of americans have made it
clear they do want health insurance
more than six p six million people
visited
the website healthcare.gov the day it
opened nearly 200 000 people picked up
the phone and called the call center
in kentucky alone
this is a state where i didn't i didn't
win kentucky
so so it's you know i know they weren't
doing it for me
in kentucky nearly 11 000 people applied
for new insurance plans in the first two
days just in one state kentucky
and many americans are finding out when
they go on the website that they'll save
a lot of money
or get health insurance for the first
time
so
my i would think that if in fact this
was going to be such a disaster that the
republicans say it's going to be that it
was going to be so unpopular they
wouldn't have to shut down the
government they could wait
nobody'd show any interest there'd be
like two people on the website
you know
everybody would then
vote for candidates who want to repeal
it
it's not as if republicans haven't had a
chance to debate the health care law it
passed the house of representatives it
passed the senate the supreme court
ruled it constitutional you remember all
this last november voters rejected the
presidential candidate that ran on a
platform to repeal it
so
the affordable care act has gone through
every single democratic process all
three branches of government
it's the law of the land
it's here to stay
i've said to republicans if there are
specific things you think can improve
the law to make it even better for
people as opposed to just getting it and
leaving 25 million people without health
insurance i'm happy to talk to you about
that
but
a republican shutdown won't
change the fact that millions of people
need health insurance
and that the affordable care act is
being implemented the shutdown does not
change that
all a shutdown
is doing is making it harder for
ordinary americans
to get by
and harder for businesses to create jobs
at a time when our economy is just
starting to gain traction again
you've heard republicans say that
obamacare will hurt the economy but the
economy has been growing and creating
jobs
the single greatest threat to our
economy and to our businesses like this
one
is not the affordable care act it's the
unwillingness of republicans in congress
to stop re-fighting a settled election
or making the demands that have nothing
to do with the budget
they need to move on to the actual
business of governing that's what will
help the economy that's what will
grow the economy that's what will put
people back to work
and more than that house republicans
need to stop careening from one crisis
to another in everything they do have
you noticed that
since they've since they've taken over
the house of representatives
we have one of these crises every three
months
have you noticed
and you keep on thinking all right well
this is going to be the last they're not
going to do this again
and then they do it again
i know you're tired of it
i'm tired of it
it doesn't mean that they're wrong on
every single issue i
i've said i'm happy to negotiate with
you on anything
i don't think any one party has a
monopoly on wisdom
but
you don't negotiate by putting a gun to
the other person's head
or worse yet by putting a gun to the
american people's head by threatening a
shutdown
and by the way even after congress
reopens your government
it's going to have to turn around very
quickly and do something else and that's
pay america's bills i want to spend a
little time on this it's called
it's something called raising the debt
ceiling and it's got a lousy name so a
lot of people end up thinking i don't
know i don't think we should raise our
debt ceiling because it sounds like
we're raising our debt
but that's not what this is about
it doesn't cost taxpayers a single dime
it doesn't grow our deficits by a single
dime it doesn't allow anybody to spend
any new money whatsoever so it's not
something
that raises our debt
what it does is allow the u.s treasury
the u.s government
to pay the bills that congress has
already racked up
i want you to think about this
if you go to a restaurant you order a
meal you eat it maybe you have some wine
maybe you have two glasses of wine
great meal
and then
you look at the tab it's pretty
expensive
and you decide
i'm not going to pay the bill
well you're not saving money
you're not being frugal you're just a
deadbeat
right
if you buy a house
and you decide man this month
i'd rather go on vacation somewhere
so i'm not going to pay my mortgage
you didn't just save yourself some money
you're just going to get foreclosed on
so you don't save money by not paying
your bills you don't reduce your debt by
not paying your bills all you're doing
is making yourself
unreliable and hurting your credit
rating
and you'll start getting those phone
calls and those notices in the mail
and the next time you try to borrow
somebody's going to say ah because you
don't pay your bills you're deadbeat
well the same is true for countries
the only thing that the debt ceiling
does is to let the u.s treasury pay for
what congress has already bought
that's why it's something that has been
routine
traditionally it's not it's not a big
deal
congress has raised it 45 times since
ronald reagan took office
this is just kind of a routine part of
keeping the government running
the last time the house republicans
flirted with not raising the debt
ceiling back in 2011 some of you
remember this
our economy took a bad hit
our country's credit rating was
downgraded for the first time
just like you'd be downgraded if you
didn't pay your mortgage
this time they are threatening to
actually force the united states to
default on its obligations for the very
first time in history
now you'll hear john boehner and mitch
mcconnell and these other republicans
say we don't want to default
but
everybody knows it's written about in
all the papers that their basic theory
is
okay if the shutdown doesn't work
then we are going to
try to get
some extra concessions out of the
president we'll put like a long laundry
list all the things that we want that we
can't get passed on our own and if we
don't get it
we'll tell them we don't
we we won't vote to
pay the country's bills we'll let the
country default
i'm not just making this up i mean it's
it's common knowledge
every reporter here knows it
and i want you to understand the
consequences of this as reckless as a
government shutdown is
as many people as being
as are being hurt by a government
shutdown
an economic shutdown that results from
default
would be dramatically worse
in a government shutdown social security
checks still go out on time
in an economic shutdown if we don't
raise the debt ceiling
they don't go out on time
in a government shutdown disability
benefits still arrive on time in an
economic shutdown they don't
in a government shutdown millions of
americans not just federal workers
everybody faces real economic hardship
in an economic shutdown
falling pensions and home values
and rising interest rates on things like
mortgages and student loans
all those things risk putting us back
into a bad recession which will affect
this company and those workers and all
of you
that's not
that that's not my
analysis that's
every economist
out there is saying the same thing we've
never done it before
and you know the united states is the
center of the world economy so
if if we screw up
everybody gets screwed up
the whole world
will have problems
which is why generally nobody's ever
thought to actually threaten not to pay
our bills
it would be the height of
irresponsibility
and that's why i've said this before i'm
going to repeat it
there will be no negotiations over this
the american people are not pawns in
some political game
you don't get to demand some ransom in
exchange for keeping the government
running you don't get to demand ransom
in exchange for keeping the economy
running
you don't get to demand
ransom for doing your most basic job
and the sooner that the republicans in
congress heed the warnings
not just of me or democrats like chris
and john but heed the warnings of the
chamber of commerce
and ceos and economists and a whole lot
of republicans outside of congress
they're all saying do not do this
they're all saying to congress do your
job
and the sooner you do your job the less
damage you'll do to our economy and to
businesses like this one
so pass a budget end the government
shutdown pay our bills prevent a
economic shutdown just vote and end this
shutdown and you should do it today so
we can get back to growing this economy
creating jobs and strengthening our
middle class
let me close just by sharing a story i
heard as i was getting ready to come
here today
many of you already know it
two years ago a mulch factory next to m
louise's
main equipment storage facility caught
fire
and most of the company's equipment was
destroyed causing millions of dollars of
damage
but even while the fire was still
burning
dozens of employees rushed over to the
facility and tried to save as much as
they could some of you were probably
there
and when they finished cutting fire
lines and spraying down the perimeter of
their own property they went over to
help their neighbors
and afterwards even though all the
employees here at m louise are on salary
even though the company had just taken a
big financial hit
sedalia and natalya paid everyone
overtime
and along with each check they included
a personalized note
saying just how much they had
appreciated the efforts of the
workers zidalia said
everybody says the biggest asset to a
business is employees
some people mean it some people don't we
actually do
so this company right here is full of
folks
who
do right by each other
they don't try to see if they can
work every angle
they don't
lie about each other
they don't try to undermine each other
they understand they're supposed to be
on the same team
you pitch in you look out for one
another
when somebody gets knocked down you help
them back up
you don't ask what can you get out of
this
because you know that success doesn't
depend
on one of you it depends on all of you
working together
well america is no different
i see that same spirit in so many cities
and towns that i visit all across the
country
it is alive and well
all across the country
it's alive and well in this community
where restaurants and businesses are
rallying around the regulars
and they're looking out for all the
dedicated public servants who've been
furloughed you've been reading stories
about restaurants they're saying you
know what if while while you're on
furlough come on
we'll give you a burger
we'll give you a meal we'll help you out
the american ideal
says
we're working together
looking out for one another
meeting our responsibilities doing our
jobs
thinking about future generations
and that's why i believe ultimately
reason and common sense will prevail
that that spirit at some point will
infiltrate washington as well
because i think the american people are
so good and so decent
they're going to get
better behavior from their government
than this
and we'll once again make sure there's a
country where you can make it if you try
so thank you everybody god bless you god
bless the united states of america